congratulations Perez Hilton you're a
jerk
now I know that you like to fit people
who dislike you into a nice little
prejudice box what are you some kind of
Claire now before you go and use this
whole event to turn yourself into some
sort of gay rights martyr let me tell
you something the fact that people can't
stand you has nothing to do with the
fact that you're gay straight people
dislike you for the same reason that
most gay people dislike you you're a
bully what she did to Miss California
was bullying 101 I'm speaking of course
not only of the pageant but your
comments afterwards okay Miss California
didn't lose because she's against gay
marriage she lost because she's a dumb
okay if she had half a brain like I did
okay she would answer the question hmm
my perez that's a very good question and
that's why I think it should be left up
to the states here comes the best part
and because the founding fathers made
some things for the states and some laws
federal here's an idea next time you
want to critique someone for being
inarticulate be articulate and like all
bullies you're a coward
as displayed by your apology okay I'm
sorry
and then you immediately taking it back
I'm not sorry anymore okay now that I
found out this will get me more
publicity um I just want to say that
actually I was being nice when I called
her a dumb [ __ ] because I was actually
wanting to use the c-word
how does it feel to have become just
like the throngs of boys who undoubtedly
stuffed you into lockers for the better
half of your high school years
Perez Hilton people don't like you well
actually all of celebrities like me
because they're even on my Twitter page
you can check it out so no nobody likes
you they say these things because they
fear your venom the fact is that you're
talentless hack who's been given a bully
pulpit solely because you're gay in an
attempt to appease the politically
correct Hollywood establishment let's
face facts you're not smart you're not
funny you're not a good writer you're
not good-looking you're not even good
with Photoshop as you childishly draw
gentles over celebrity faces did you
know what happens in
real-world when Billy Ray Cyrus finds
out that you're referring to a 16 year
old daughter as [ __ ] Cyrus he would
knock your teeth out of your fat little
face
folks am I wrong you know Hilton's gonna
see this so be sure to let him know what
you think Christian conservatives aren't
happy with you not because of the fact
that you like men they simply judged you
by your actions okay I have friends in
Hollywood who totally support me in this
and hate Miss California and there are
Christians
okay the term Christian and Hollywood is
very different it basically means they
stay away from hard drugs any time it
gets worse than cocaine I ask myself
what would Jesus do to see what a vulgar
little pustule you are one needs look no
further than your videos right here on
YouTube um
you're just humma phobic ah there it is
the homophobe card what does homophobia
even mean do liberal PC activists really
think that everybody who voted YES on
eight is like oh no they're queer
everywhere that's clutters let me just
get this straight
if somebody personally disagrees with
the lifestyle or agenda that must mean
that they're afraid of it I just want to
know if those are the rules because in
that case I guess I'm a druggie faux I'm
a hippie folk and in your case I mean
I'm not just more runoff oh oh I'm being
so bad today I always knew you was a
queer